so this is a headline man crushed to
death by robot in South Korea autonomous
robot mistakes man for box of vegetables
slamming him against the cyor belt to
his
death oh my God why are you
laughing just turn him into a vegetable
autonomous robot mistakes man oh yeah I
turned him into yeah
sorry sorry you did yeah I'm not going
to yeah wow I mean it's a little further
than a vegetable yeah more like boxed
wine that's
true they put that robot on Titan
submersible
Mode God somebody brought that up the
other day and I was like God where did
they go when was that that was like ah
the good old days I miss I miss that
[__] submersible yeah that was such a
moment when was that may yeah 2019 when
was that no it was pretty recent I know
it was so recent yeah we're everyone's
but it was just like the way the way
that dominated the media and then was
just gone just moves too fast now and I
don't think it's because we're getting
older I think it just is moving faster
yeah they're doing it someone speeding
up I think they are yeah I think they
notched it up a little bit I know Tik
Tok probably 1.5 speed yeah exactly
sorry Q if Tik Tok gets brought up you
have to do that
yeah
damn yeah time to be moving fast yeah I
was watching Alina like she was cons
like watching some video that I would
watch but she has that feature cuz not
everyone has it on Tik Tok where you
hold your thumb down and it goes 2x
really I have I think I'm missing a lot
of features on yeah her her version that
I don't have it let me see I love it um
I use it all the time cuz my you know my
brain is I can't watch things on normal
speed anymore unless it's on a smart
fridge it was something pretty morbid it
was about about I don't know some murder
or something and she was I'm looking at
her she's just trying to get to the
ending yeah so I'm
like going oh my God I didn't know I
could do
that isn't that and then what if I hold
it three time is there any way to it
just does two times that's it yeah okay
why would you want to watch cool am I
just watching my own content maybe yeah
oh my new song
dentist so you're telling me it works
hold on I
got new stuff that
just so you're telling me so it also
works on pickle in the fridge my other
song that's really interesting well you
guys are both no case I phoners yeah
that is bold that is so sleep you just
break it every day you just buy a new
one yeah yeah I don't give a [__] that
is it is its own case yeah couldn't give
less of a [__] yeah do you ever have a
broken phone for a few weeks no cuz
these phones don't [__] break anymore
you can drop them
no bre this how when's the last time you
saw someone with a cracked phone today
but I saw today but was it like an
iPhone 8 exctly no no no they were both
old wait I want to try it watch this cuz
you know
what
whoa oh [__] hold on I'm going to shoot
it with a gun yeah you ever have this
thing where you feel like you've seen a
million funny Tik toks and then you go
through your likes and you're like
you're like yeah this [__] [__] like
that all the I'm like whenever Kelsey's
like I got to show you some Tik toks I'm
like oh I got so many to show you too
exactly and the last one the last one I
lik this from like 2016 and I'm like how
did do Tik Tok even around yeah I've
actually never gotten over this there's
two Tik toks of Cody that I'm sure a
billion people have seen but there's the
one where the guy's head is like
steaming and then it cuts to you and you
go are you on fire yeah and then that
other one where you match up what you
know about roll down in the deep and you
mash it into another song and it sounds
horrible now I like the one that went
crazy over Co where that person drank
all those Bobo balls and you're like
what the [__] is
that yeah this this video is are you
reallyu it's so simple there we have it
I've just finished one of the most
intense workouts I've done for a while
what like what is going on are you on
fire it hits every time are wait go to
the go to the one with the mash it's
like the next video or two videos later
you guys are making me feel really
special this is fire this is what they
call fire content this is the last good
thing I've ever made I
guess n s m remember when we used to do
like them on
stage like Tik Tok to me feels like it's
three years old but it's been around for
[__] so many years oh yeah when we do
like the you know tractor pulling check
what you're talking about no on stage
when we yeah we'd be like we'd say you
know we'd go like my cousins have no
teeth check we'd be like in you know the
South or something we pull it up and
everyone be quiet that was such a moment
remember that yes yeah yeah we we bombed
it
yeah check what are the new things on
Tik Tok bro I think my greatest
performing Tik toks is just me not
talking I've had the most where I don't
speak yeah oh you just you just react
right or I just smile it's it started
yeah yeah yeah I know that I know that
Trend yeah I just did it with this
[__] fish getting let me see it put
through a band saw wait also you know
what I just you know what just came
swimming out of my memory the other day
what that woman oh there he is not that
one that keep going he's that woman who
used to eat pickles ASMR remember her no
I'll show
[Music]
you it just hit every time it really
does the best joke ever yeah I just
genuinely love that first video too
just for some reason it makes me feel so
good wait look up pickle pickle lady
crunch
ASMR you don't like it no it just made
me feel really weird I love
it listen when she takes a fresh new
bite it's a
[Music]
Triumph that texture is crazy and those
half those half
pickles isn't that Lit don't you want
one do we have any pickles
here dude the it like she's doing a bit
yeah it sounds like she's eating rocks
or something the texture sounds so wild
holy
it's every time she takes a bite that
didn't make you feel good no it gives
you the it gives you like a a that's
that yeah I don't know I floss kind of
shreds a little bit and you're like oh I
get that with velcro that makes sense
yeah always just regular velcro your
velcro in your teeth yeah yeah no when I
hear velcro ripping it just makes my
teeth no way really damn I hate the like
knife on a ceramic plate or whatever
yeah yeah for sure yeah oh my god oh
okay okay D chip close
enough oh wait they're not they're not
like pickles though they're slices we're
not going to get the same crunch
floor new new carpet new
carpet this is a
[Laughter]
199 this is such a different animal
though how is it no you know what are
the best butter butter P or what's what
are the sweet on bread and butter oh my
those I'm sorry I didn't realize there
was people that didn't like those I
didn't realize there were people that
did oh am I the weird one here no I
didn't know there was a community that
had anything to do with everybody likes
those likes what bread and butter
pickles the sweet on this is where you
realize you're in The Truman Show you're
like all the people in my life say they
love them like yes we love do love them
we love your podcast too you're so good
at podcasting you have cool opinions
like that
one look at all these pickles bread and
butter oh I love why are they called
that cuz they're such a Mis cuz that's
what it's for it's four sandwiches it
sweetens up the sandwich a little bit oh
well you turkey sandwich a little bit of
you can sell me on it yeah oh dude I
love these so much I can't believe you
guys are
weird